obviously bitcoin went down a lot uh
start the year uh december and january
uh pretty big price drawdowns but now
bitcoin has come back it didn't die
didn't go to zero all the bears are
wrong they're stunned in disbelief uh
let's start with uh just price weighted
by hourly uh perps funding rate
obviously uh last week and week before
you were talking a lot about the funding
rates and kind of waiting for negative
funding what are you seeing now what's
this telling us yeah so i mean we got it
uh you know we talked about derivatives
a lot here um and and really we like
this graphic a lot to show kind of uh
the bearish or bullishness in the
derivative market so uh when there's
negative funding and essentially what
that means is that derivative bets you
have longs paying shorts i'm sorry
shorts paying longs
when okay let me spit it out here uh
when this line is read what you have is
is longs are being paid by shorts so uh
when you see kind of a short squeeze in
bitcoin and bitcoin is going vertical
oftentimes what's happening is in
derivative markets you have uh shorts
that are being forced uh forced to
become buyers or they're actually being
liquidated margin called in the legacy
system that's what it's called and so
you have kind of that organic spot price
but oftentimes when you see these
volatile moves
at tops and at bottoms oftentimes it's
really the derivative markets that's
driving the price action uh and there's
these forced unwinds that are happening
so we we kept talking about will talks
about it a lot uh when we're gonna get a
regime of like negative funding what
that means is that you're getting times
where your shorts are paying long to
enter a position they're paying longs to
sit in a derivative long position and so
we saw that we saw that at the bottom
and we saw as price was going up funding
was staying negative so so what that
means was that that perpetual swap price
was under the spot market price so
whether it's on finance or ftx perpetual
swap or bitmex it was under say the
price of bitcoin on coinbase it was
under a spot bitcoin market price and so
that you can think of like i like this
analogy a lot when funding is negative
when when you see that positioning under
the spot price it's like a beach ball
underwater and so uh it wasn't as
significant as say march of 2020 or even
this summer but this kind of recent
squeeze we've got this you know we've
almost gotten kind of vertical to 44 000
or around there um it's because of you
know the derivative bets that have
started to really unwind and so uh you
know that's what happens when when bears
get uh too bearish at the bottom
got it and so if we look at the supply
held by whales that seems to uh be
significantly changing and they just
seem to be gobbling up bitcoin right now
holding as much of it as they possibly
can
yeah so we have here we have uh
basically the 30-day percentage change
of whales and retail and so uh with the
blue pattern is the blue color is when
both of these cohorts are accumulating
and so you can kind of see like you can
think of whales as like the smart money
and maybe they're not so smart just as
much as they they really can uh you know
change the market structure just with
how much capital they have um so when
you see both retail and whales
accumulating uh it's usually you know
somewhat of a bottom or like it's a
pretty good time to buy and so recently
we seen we saw retailers continue to buy
the entire drawdown whales were actually
distributing and recently that flipped
so both whales and retail are big buyers
here and we've seen that over the last
month or so and so
i think that's a trend that's that's
pretty good to see and we'll see if it
continues into the future
got it and so then if we move and we
look at actual uh retail entities and uh
the whales when you start to compare
these uh over like the 30 day percent
change to me
what is a little bit hard to understand
maybe you can kind of help clarify this
is it doesn't seem like there's been
that big of a
kind of delta or movement uh since maybe
december or so how do you uh look at
this and then if you look over kind of
the last few years what are you seeing
here
yeah so i think uh maybe i think our
slides were mixed i i changed it uh so
right right now i'm looking at the
supply held by only whale entities um so
so we're seeing that that accumulation
happened um and and we saw that
distribution at the at the basically the
top of the bull market and into the
downturn and we saw that distribution
kind of flip uh from november as uh
as as that cpi print came in really hot
and powell said you know hey we're wrong
inflation's not not transitory uh and
you saw somewhat of the smart money like
the you know the big whales start to
distribute a little bit so that's
flipped in accumulation mode again and
really like you know these these 30-day
trends um it's interesting to monitor uh
but but the reality is uh for the most
part bitcoin is always in an
accumulation mode for for most or a lot
of market participants and new market
participants uh it's really just kind of
uh incumbents how much are they
controlling what are they doing and so
we're seeing that accumulation happen
again uh and rightfully so with bitcoin
kind of down 50 from the all-time highs
maybe not now i think we're actually
like 40 30 off the bottom uh so
quite a good bounce but uh it's good to
see that those whales that traditional
smart money crowd step in big at 30 low
30k ring